[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I know one thing
never wake up
this family
[Music]
is our Fortress
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna be late Lucy it's about
mother has she ever tried to see me no
she hasn't kit I haven't seen you since
Christmas Dylan we have to plan the
wedding Mimi I'm gonna get out of this
town go all the way to California how
are you gonna get there I found her out
with this guy what you can't go by
yourself with some guy so then come with
me are you serious yes they're taking us
to La yeah
this February
take a chance hello how about Lucy
sneaking away in the middle of the night
you are coming back now share the
adventure
I'm not sleeping here
[Music]
the journey
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't listen to this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a guy
a guy and and that's my car that's the
one thing that hasn't been taken over by
checks Paramount Pictures and zomba
films present in association with MTV
Films
a story about the dreams that drive us I
wanted to find my mom I know she wants
to see me scared can I help you it's me
llama Lucy
places life takes us what we have is now
and right now we have each other
and the friends that Go the Distance
we don't have enough money to get the
car fixed I have an idea
all right next contestants
[Applause]
[Music]
Britney Spears Anson Mount Zoe Saldana
Karen Manning
[Music]
Crossroads
you Jake Shelly
we'd like to talk to you about a fresh
start on a new world
be making a difference
I became a marine for the hardship told
myself I can pass any test a man can
pass
thing worth fighting for ladies and
gentlemen
you are not in Kansas anymore
you're on Pandora
[Music]
you should see your faces we have an
indigenous population called the Nabi
they are very hard to kill this is why
we're here because this little gray rock
sells for 20 million a kilo their
Village happens to be resting on the
richest deposit and they need to
relocate those Savages are threatening
our whole operation we're on the brink
of war and you're supposed to be finding
a diplomatic solution
the concept is to drive these remotely
controlled bodies called avatarsing
they're grown from human DNA
mixed with DNA of the natives Marine in
an avatar body has a potent mix you get
me what I need I'll see to it you get
your legs big your real legs oh yeah sir
looks like you this is your avatar
just relax and let your mind go blank
shouldn't be hard for you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I haven't gotten lost in the woods have
you you forget what team you're playing
for
strong prey on the week and nobody does
a thing you've got one hour you knew
this would happen everything changed
I think it's crazy here poor Rich is
rolling and there's no stopping him
we're going up against gunships as bows
and arrows
yes we better stop it
they've sent us a message that they can
take whatever they want
but we will send them a message
that this
this is our land
hey buddy I got the good stuff
put your hands on the clock I think this
is funny no
no
[Music]
never forget where you came from
get ready
you want me to teach you how to be a kid
but I just remember
who are you not from the service
there's 22 murders in the last four
years I'm doing this my way
you know why
after us she's just a girl take care of
it I don't know of something or someone
hurt you before
talk to me what do you want to know
anything something about you
I was nine my parents were killed
never forget where you came from
foreign
[Music]
never forget where you came from
think your world is safe
it is an illusion
enjoy these final moments of peace
by now all of you have heard what
happened in London
man who did it
he's one of our top agents
your commanders have committed a crime I
cannot forgive
none of you are safe
[Music]
foreign
have I got your attention now
I request permission to go after him
Starfleet is not about Vendetta Kirk
maybe it should be sir
you're not actually going after this guy
are you I have no idea what I'm supposed
to do I only know what I can do
[Music]
we will not fit
[Music]
I am not sure that qualifies
you murder innocent men and women I will
make you answer for what you did
I will walk over your cold Corpses
outnumbered
we come out shooting
that bought everything
that is where your great grandmother
Gaga grew up your great great
grandfather was once the richest man in
Boston so how come we're so poor
would you like to see the inside are we
allowed you can't just walk up and knock
on people's doors sweetheart it's Boston
they're practically expecting us
my father was diagnosed manic depressive
in 1967. can I help you my
great-grandmother grew up in this house
and well I wanted to show it to my girl
I'm sorry but I don't give tours
he met my mother and told her all about
his nervous breakdowns she didn't care
why can't daddy live here with us
Daddy's still recovering from his
breakdown he's a way better hook than
you so they got married and they had me
oh and then my sister I got into
Columbia you can't take the girls to New
York here's my proposal we love you bye
you move in with the girls and you take
care of them we're gonna be late for
school okay
it'd be good for me to have a routine
hold on hold on yes yes a routine
have some breakfast the most important
meal of the day Amelia let's go that's a
lot of routine you can do it is this
something to do with feminism
[Music]
you're all welcome to come to our
apartment we don't want people to see
how we live big deal how you live it's
not your fault girls tell me it has no
floor it has no floor I scavenge these
from your kitchen
foreign
why do you have so much stuff our dad is
totally polar bear bipolar
probably sorry you married him never
I love you you want me to pick you up
after school no I'll be here at three
my ex-husband would never do what you're
doing I think it's so evolved we do most
men would be completely emasculated by
having their wife go off to be the
breadwinner oh thank you
[Music]
I come from Earth a planet of Outlaws
my name is Peter Quill
is one other name you might know me by
Star-Lord
who a Star-Lord man legendary Outlook
guys
forget it
[Music]
so here we are
a Thief
two thugs
an assassin and a maniac
but we're not gonna stand by his evil
wipes out of the Galaxy
I guess we're stuck together partners
are you telling me the fate of 12
billion people
he's in the hands of these criminals
oh
business with me
I look around you know what I see
closers but life's giving us a chance to
do what something good
something bad a bit of both
wow what the hell I don't got that long
a lifespan anyway
[Music]
I'm high on believing
you're in love with me
I'm rude
ain't no thing like me except me they
call themselves The Guardians of the
Galaxy
this might not be the best idea
[Music]
I've Got a Feeling
[Music]
follow me you need to see something
special all the world is made of stories
and all of those stories are right here
in the book of life but The Greatest
Story begins on the day of the day a day
when Spirits pass Between Worlds and
anything can happen ah look at the two
best friends oh in love with the same
girl
you two are acting like fool wait me too
you picked you picked yourself a feisty
one
how about
[Applause]
I bet that Maria will marry Joaquin
very well by the ancient rules
The Wager is sent
[Music]
so beautiful
fix this for me old friend I may not be
the time of hero Maria but I swear with
all my heart I will never stop loving
you
another
where am I
[Music]
welcome to the land of the remember
don't try to take it all in at once
this is incredible epic fiestas every
day oh you can eat churros my lady
please help me reunite with the love of
my life
if you complete these tasks you will see
Maria again
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me
[Applause]
[Music]
hey girl
I get that a lot The Book of Life hold
it I know exactly what to play
you got what I need
wow that totally captivated her
[Music]
[Applause]
don't look back look up
uh I think we're about to have some
company
start the car what what
go go go
Laura this is
me
parallel contact babe well you know
you've always said that you've wished
you'd met me earlier
here I am
do you remember this I mean this is
happening to me it already happened to
you right
unless it works more like a Multiverse
where each triple creates nothing entire
wallpapers my God we watch too many
movies
[Music]
so bunny 50 is it really bad
it's not great find him
[Music]
get ready to run
oh
[Music]
foreign
you know what you have to do stop time
travel matter being invented boom
what's your plan well I'm not gonna
explain my plan to a 12 year old nerd
with it
but I know somebody who does Dad
I'm the Godfather of time travel the
atom project
[Music]
a kid
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
spent 30 years
trying to get away from the me that was
you and
I'll tell you what
you were the best part all along
it's good to be so smart
I should get to be so dumb
[Music]